I'm gonna be talking about how you can
build and and kind of machine learning
pipelines in pachyderm but not in the
way that you kind of typically expect
right what I'm gonna focus on mostly
today is how you know machine learning
pipelines in general are missing a big
thing which is you know something called
data provenance which I'm pretty sure a
lot of you are familiar with let me get
started so as data scientist we love you
guys know who that is right I'm not that
old right okay cool that's data from
Star Trek if you were wondering my geek
credentials there they are I just used a
Star Trek reference in my presentation
but more importantly we love big data
right and then we love it when it gets
combined with machine learning right so
these these presents a pretty powerful
options especially I'm just gonna take
this off the mic because I like to move
around especially companies out there
right they're thinking if I take this
big pile of data that I've been
collecting for years and I apply it to
these new or apply to this new field
called well not new but this field of
machine learning all of a sudden I get
these mind-blowing insights from this
stuff and I'm just gonna hire a bunch of
these people called data scientists I'm
gonna give them access to data and I'm
gonna let them run right and let them go
and so packet are we deal with this a
lot actually so companies have put a lot
of investment into machine learning and
they've hired a bunch of data scientists
and they've given them all this data and
they're kind of just sitting there at
their big desks and wondering when am I
gonna be Amazon right what am I gonna be
these next big players it's because like
immediately when people get jumped in
they get dumped in they immediately go
to these two steps right I'm gonna focus
on connecting data to maths and then I'm
gonna expect some sort of output and
then I'm gonna be Amazon or Google or
open AI and so then we start to think
about maybe some inference and
prediction if we're getting real fancy
but in actuality and I think you guys
understand this the most out of anyone
there's a lot more steps involved right
when we start thinking about a complete
holistic machine learning pipeline and
these even aren't all the steps right
there's still a lot of things to be done
and there's still a lot of things that
you as a company may do differently on
different steps but one of the biggest
challenges that we really see is
in that in order for machine learning to
really reach its full potential there's
three major things that need to happen
one data itself needs to have the same
production practices as code right if
you think about the last 10 15 years in
software development code has done a
tremendous amount of change with how we
deploy it how we use it not just the
languages and frameworks that were
created but how we move from one version
of that code to the other right and I'm
more specifically talking about git
the way we have ability to version
control roll things back integrate and
test it on very specific versions of
code make you know is made it possible
what it can do today in production but
data hasn't inherited a lot of those
same principles we've moved a lot
forward we've moved the needle forward
there but dienes always kind of stayed
in that same static thing it's a it's
something uploaded to an object store it
lives in a data Lake but there is
absolutely no versioning so it's this
it's this highly protected resource and
for good reason but we we just kind of
throw it at things and then we expect an
output but when we want to explain what
happened it becomes very very difficult
the other thing is developers they need
to be empowered not not restricted right
so we need to give data scientists and
developers the ability to work with this
data but not with this impending sense
of doom of if I mess anything up it's
gonna destroy everything that last known
good state of data is gone and I have to
email someone to roll a backup that's
gonna make wake them up at 3:00 in the
morning right they need the ability to
be able to be empowered to you know
experiment freely but also move quickly
and use the right languages and
frameworks that work for that project
not because everyone has used that
language forever
and finally organization-wide confidence
and this really kind of comes down to I
think this is personally my most
important thing when I think about
applied machine learning today in the
enterprise especially if we start to
think about responsible machine learning
and AI and data science in general when
we have data and we use algorithms to
gain new powerful insights in that data
we need to be able to be able to explain
those outcomes at any given point and be
able to explain them clearly and quickly
and if we think critically about that
and more specific use case
if someone is applying for a bank loan
and they're going through the website to
do that and they put in all their
information but behind the scenes the
bank has invested a lot of money into
training what is a good candidate for a
loan and what isn't if we don't take a
look at how we train that model we
create bias right and I'm pretty sure
you guys are all well aware of AI and
m/l bias but the thing is is if someone
says especially with things like gdpr if
we if someone says hey wait a minute why
was I rejected I want specific details
as to why my loan was rejected if the
company is using a heavy machine
learning model to do that explaining
that outcome becomes very very difficult
if not sometimes impossible and so a
pachyderm well you know where I'm kind
of work to help communities of
developers out there leverage the
platform these are kind of the big
things that we want to solve and I'm
gonna show you guys how we solve that
and kind of show you guys our platform a
little bit but more just kind of give
concept around best practice and how an
end-to-end machine learning pipeline and
all the characteristics it really should
have to be successful all right so what
are some of the biggest obstacles when
we think about end to end machine
learning or end-to-end pipelines there's
a lot of obstacles and these are just a
summary of some of the big ones I'm
pretty sure you have your own individual
major obstacles right one is data
divergence really we can sum this up to
you know big if you change anything you
change everything so keeping track of
all of those changes ISM is next to
impossible without some sort of
provenance or without some sort of data
lineage keeping in play and if you're
making decisions from this and when you
think about models of being you know
trained autonomously decisions and and
the history of those decisions get lost
and in just clouds of noise really very
quickly and then of course there's to
Lincoln trains I use Jupiter notebooks I
use Python directly well you guys are
noobs I use C++ or you know whatever
there's this big argument of which
language is better I was talking about
it with a fella at lunch you know of
whether Jupiter notebooks are worthy of
production or not and we were just going
back and forth and it's it's you know
there wasn't a complete opposite side of
the stance it was just we had different
approaches to
things and if we want to do if we want
to have teams of data scientists working
together on a to solve a singular
solution we really need to make sure
that they're empowered to use the tools
that they know best or at least the
tools that's right for the project just
because the rest of the applications
written in Java doesn't mean we need to
really introduce Java into this right it
just needs to be the language or
framework that works for the problem at
hand and then of course most importantly
again coming back to that provenance
idea everything needs to be reproducible
if we think about it we're data
scientist we are scientist most machine
learning and AI stuff that's happening
today is still missing that
reproducibility one of my favorite
github repos that I follow it is a
machine learning paper with code and
it's just a list of all the machine
learning papers that also add code
simply because there's this big idea of
we're publishing all this great material
but nobody's showing us how to reproduce
it and how we can recreate these results
and it's pretty important and pachyderm
is you know it's one of its main things
as making results immediately
reproducible I'll kind of show you guys
what that means here in a second so to
kind of sum up that last side if slide
if mmm if data means the same production
practices code
well that's version control for data
essentially get for data if we need to
be have if we need developers or
scientists to be empowered well that
means containers and containers data
pipelines and that becomes really
powerful here in a second which I'll
also show you but then it's also being
able to instantly reconstruct any past
output or decision that's imperative
that's boilerplate that's that's basic
science right if we're thinking about
using math to prove something we need to
be able to show our work right and so
that's data lineage and that's these are
all things that pachyderm really focuses
to provide from an open source
standpoint I'll kind of skip this slide
because that's more businessing we want
to get down to the details so data
versioning right what does that mean
right so we have the ability to identify
and revert any bad data changes if you
think about a data set we actually just
released a version 1.8 and one of those
functionalities is being able to take
structured data and then automatically
split it up so it can be distributed
across a cluster but that sounds pretty
awesome in a sense but what it really
does - in the sense of Providence and
versioning is what was a single database
dump or a single file that was
structured data when it gets committed
and split in a pachyderm repo each row
can be split up into its own individual
file and then inherence data or aleca
versioning or tracking system so
everything gets a commit ID so what was
previously one big commit or one big
file is cannot be split up into chunks
that where every single chunk has a
commit ID and can be tracked back
completely so if we think about oh I
want to run an ETL pipeline and I want
to do all these things to this data to
shape it to prepare it for said outcome
you can immediately recall and go back
to what was it that I inserted if you
look at the graphic on the right one of
these things you know is not like the
other right one all works on the road or
driving ones a boat in water and we can
see how data gets injected sometimes and
it's not like the others and so we need
to remove it and so we need to remove it
quickly and then not affect the
stability of things right
so that becomes really powerful and so
that's one of the things that we produce
and I'll show you guys an example of
that the containerized pipeline I can
summarize this to really quickly write
docker containers more specifically
docker containers running on kubernetes
this is how we accomplish both the
ability to give you know developers with
the freedom of the tools that they need
to use this is great for ops if you have
ops that constantly gives you push back
of oh no I'm not going to install that
because that means a lot of work for me
but if you ask them if they have docker
they support docker most of the time who
they say yes or they're evaluating so
pachyderm leverages containers and more
importantly well equally importantly I
should say kubernetes and so that gives
us the ability to scale write and
leverage things like GPUs and run pretty
much anywhere right on Prem off Prem in
the cloud hybrid cloud and so but more
importantly I think to you guys what
containers in these containerized
pipelines really allow us to do is to
take our whole pipeline like I showed
you in the earlier all those steps and
instead of thinking them or thinking of
them as as things that we stack on one
or another more of like as as a you know
kind of string together thing to where
everything is independent
another and then you can follow the
individual output of everything so one
example that we had is I was working
with a customer who does genomic data
science and they had all these samples
coming in from the field and different
areas of the world and they would have
to do for each individual bench
scientist they had to do their own kind
of ETL or their own refactoring of this
sample data so they could get it to that
bench scientist and if you imagine for
the computational team that was running
all this that was all ad hoc everything
was independent there wasn't any really
reproducible steps and so that create a
lot of challenges and so this company
was hiring these really brilliant
individuals to basically you know manage
scripts all day and so that was really
frustrating and but when they use
pachyderm they're able to kind of
declare things independent of one
another and then tie them together so
where these where these behaviors are
similar but not quite the same they can
define them at different pipelines and
then chain these pipelines together it
also you know with you know another big
thing and I put in this puzzle piece
over here is the ability now that code
inherits a lot of those production
practices or data we can start doing
things like CI CD in a more real way in
a more tangible way because we're
testing data just like we do code so one
example of a why should say pseudo and
and machine learning pipeline is a pull
request I actually have opening cube
flow right now but it's you know really
what I can what it shows you is how you
can take you know data you can
pre-process it you can version it throw
it into your training you can then you
know leverage cube flow and Seldon to
not only run that on actual hardware or
distribute those workloads but also you
celled in to like serve different parts
or model so that kind of builds on the
previous slide of where every aspect of
your pipeline is defined by you and you
can use the tools and services that make
sense
so if Selden is something that you guys
used to serve Mongols out that's as it's
super simple to implement it's just
adding another pipeline you know
pipeline spec into your whole pipeline
and it becomes very simple to just kind
of chain these things together and
maintain provenance and lineage
throughout the whole thing
to Providence which I kind of talked
about I've talked about several times
it's tracking every version of that data
in code so if we put input something and
then we output something or we change it
in between everything is tracked and
everything gets a commit ID so we can
trace it all the way back and say where
did this things start and how did it get
end up this way and I don't know about
you guys but that has helped me a lot
with some of my models simply because
you know it data gets restructured or
changed at one point moved from one data
frame to another data frame and things
kind of merged around and then I'm
sitting there for four hours going why
am why is this thing totally wrong was
because of this at one point I did this
structure or this change in my data
frame and it messed everything up and I
wasn't able to really track that without
some sort of provenance there's just why
pachyderm has made it so much easier for
me to do those things
quick stack diagram you know basically
like I said we run on top of kubernetes
we have this pachyderm engine that is
you know that lives kind of on top we
have this pachyderm file system similar
to not the Hadoop file system but some
of the same concepts are there but
basically distributed file system across
you know a large cluster and then that's
all our open source stuff we have some
enterprise stuff you know that's that's
kind of I think not so interesting to
this audience but you know it's like
dashboards statistics and access
controls more things that I think ops
would be more important are interested
in but realistically everything that
I've been showing you today so far you
can completely use in our open source
engine and it's really powerful and
really interesting so let's go through
this in action and then I'm gonna go to
a little bit of a demo where we can dive
into actual code and examples which is
what I think you guys want to go to but
I think it's important for us to think
critically about what we mean when we
say data provenance and data lineage and
the impact that that has as we as we
think about or hopefully in the back of
your mind you're thinking about how am i
tackling that and my workflows right
irregardless of pachyderm but if we
think about gdpr i think we all have at
least some familiarity with this in some
regard you heard about it or you know
those you know that acronym but
basically gives you know European
citizens a bunch of rights own to how
their data is used in how its protected
one of those is being able to just the
right to an explanation right so if some
if you get an outcome
you have the right to get a full human
interpreted you know basic cause of what
happened and why it happened that way
but if you haven't you know if these if
these companies you know if companies
are you're leveraging machine learning
there's still a lot of that black box
and so if we think about it if we have a
bunch of users in a database and we
train that you know trained a machine
learning model to say yes or no whether
someone gets a bank loan or if I want to
make a not throwing shade in Amazon but
they they wrote a big article about how
their job
AI system they shut it down because it
was by source women for this kind of
similar reason they threw a bunch of
data at it but they didn't really
understand what data was being used to
train that model and once they did a
really deep analysis they understood
that it had a lot of masculine language
in it and so candidates that had more
feminine language in their resumes were
getting bumped to the bottom and they
didn't find that out until way late and
millions of dollars were invested but
you know so and the concept of GDP are
it's this kind of the same right so we
have this database of users or database
of content or data we're training it to
do a decision we're deploying that and
hoping that everything goes our fingers
crossed right nobody throws a fit but
with GDP our that makes it you know a
lot you know users have a backed by law
way to get you know an explanation of
that outcome and so if you don't have
some sort of provenance or lineage or
both in terms of technology as well as
business process getting to that output
really tracing back to why that decision
was made is a very arduous process and
sometimes impossible which can really
create some problems so but with
pachyderm it kind of starts to take a
little bit of a different shape right so
as I said everything that you put into a
repo and pachyderm gets a community
right think exactly the same way as you
do you check in code with git when you
when you check in new code it gets a
commit ID it's in a repo it's you know
then you know you can deploy your
containers to do your hair all your
models and then you can serve that model
out whether Seldon or whatever you want
to use and we get to that same point to
where Jared goes wait why was you know
or I don't want my mom you know I don't
why was I not approve
or in this specific case you know I
don't want my information to be used to
create automated systems which is
another gdpr right you can say that I
don't want my data to be used in any any
kind of automated training way so what
you can do though if that's a really
simple problem to solve is Jared raises
hand says I don't want my data to be
used for that thing you just can delete
that file the rest or the with the with
the pack control you can delete it and
then the rest of the data set and all
the model gets retrained on that exact
same data set we don't have to call
someone to open up a database and find
that user record delete it then read
dump it and then try to get it all the
way through the pipeline again that's
that's all that all becomes automated so
it becomes pretty powerful when you
start thinking about not just deletes
edits or ads or you know what have you
so yeah so this is pachyderm in
60-seconds because i really want to get
to the good stuff but I have to go
through these slides so that we can come
go some concepts right so pachyderm is
an enterprise-grade
data science platform that allows you to
build these multistage pipelines that
are language agnostic and main complete
reproducibility of code throughout or
and data throughout the entire thing
right so it's version control for data
its containerized data pipelines and
then you know concept around datum
provenance on top is everyone okay you
can guys give me a thumbs up if there
any questions to hear I'm gonna go to
the demo just a couple thumbs up I'm
seeing a couple so I'm gonna move on all
right this I can't do with holding a mic
so I'm gonna drop this here and try to
stay still all right so let's open this
up real quick
enhance and hence enhance
okay and then let me go to our dashboard
real quick cuz that's an easy place to
start so this is my dag right I have
some sorry I have some different things
to find these blue hexagons define
repose think of them similarly or
exactly the same as you would a git repo
and then these green icons are like my
pipeline specs right these are the
instruction set that I'm giving to
pachyderm to do things and we'll take a
look at each one of these but from the
dag you can see oh here in my images
repo I have a picture of an airplane and
it's just an airplane right nothing
special there and you can see I have one
file in there you can see it was it was
done in one commit and we can even take
a look you can see it's on the master
branch right has some really interesting
information here and so what's happens
is I also have this model repo that has
basically the pre train model from
tensorflow right I didn't I didn't want
to go through training a whole model
here otherwise we'd be here until
Thanksgiving and we'd miss out on
delicious Turkey but so I have this pre
train model and you can take a look at
this pipeline spec which i think is just
easier to open up in the command line so
if I do them detect or actually was do
model so you can see this is my
pachyderm pipeline spec it's incredibly
simple it's just a JSON file I give it a
name I pointed a repo and then I you
know pointed this frozen in inference
graph but you guys understand you know I
think you guys all generally understand
that I'm just telling you no pachyderm
to say you know take a look at this
training repo pull images and come you
know and then leverage this frozen
inference graph in fact I think if I and
then you know output something so that's
kind of this detect phase 2 so that
detect model is going to take point in
that as well so if I do detect this is a
little bit more of a detailed pipeline
but seems pretty simple I'm doing is I'm
giving it an input and impact me we can
give it multiple input sources in
different ways and like joins or crosses
I'll save that for another time but
basically I'm just saying take a look at
the images repo you know and then take a
look at that model repo and then do the
object detection which is that Python
inference model and then there we go
right so that's the basic outline of
these shapes right training is more
symbolic than actual reality because
again we're using that frozen inference
graph but you can see how all these
steps are kind of then tagged so let's
take a look and actually put a file in
there so if I go into image
and I do PAC control put file but not
airplane we have dogs because he doesn't
love dogs
jpg boom and then try to see if I can
catch it it goes pretty fast yeah
okay so that I think is already gone so
we can see in the detect phase dogs dogs
is already shown up and oh I should have
shown that before right that airplane
picture we input it then it went and did
the inference growl or did the object
detection through tensorflow and then it
outputs the you know object detection so
airplane was in there to start but I
just put in dog as you see and then you
can see I'll look at that some adorable
beagles and we can do this all day long
right and so if we do real quick if I
just do packet roll you can see these
are the different repos I have if I do
PAC control list file images master you
can see I have my different files in
there and then I can do PAC control
inspect all I can show you we have a lot
of inspect but if we do to inspect file
we new images or I'm sorry detect master
dogs jpg you can see yeah I can pull out
details here I'll try to see if I can
show you something else that's pretty
cool let's to see if I can catch one
real quick
let me try to put kites in there
a tape quicker Nick type quicker I
didn't type quick enough oh well we'll
see the history of it you can't is goes
the old saying you can't type when
someone's looking at you I have like 50
plus faces looking at so you can see so
every job that I put in there so every
time I put an image in that input repo
or that Images repo pachyderm notice to
change then created a job that was
defined by my pipeline spec so it says
you know take images from here you know
use this inference graph to do object
detection and then put them in this
output repo and you can see every state
is tracked and then I can see that
everything has a commit ID so every time
that model or every time something was
done through the image detection it
created you know a community so then I
can see that if I do I'm just gonna copy
this somebody up a control and inspect
you can see that I have a commit ID here
and then I also have a parent ID and if
I go back and trace that you're gonna
see how it went through those different
things it had a new child and parent
assigned to it at every stage and change
so if I wanted to figure out how this
dog or what model was used to detect
this dog this image of a dog I can
immediately follow that all the way back
and you can see the provenance is
tracked here as well so we can see that
look it came from images and then you
know its output you know parent are all
located here so you can see that
Providence is never lost as even if it's
going from different repos and going
through different changes and so I guess
with that I spoke very fastly to the
slides and I kind of you know rush to
the demo just because of time but I want
to open it up for questions let's throw
stuff at me let's explore things here if
we can that's the best way to do it yes
I saw you go up first to go for it
[Music]
yes so you can use and I'm just gonna go
right here so his question was in case
you couldn't hear the mic is he was
wondering - no I did a put file to
insert that file into a repository to
kick off all the pipeline stuff but he
wants to know can it just be like
automated we feel like a user request or
some sort of hook or cron or something
like that and so yes so if we go to our
I'm just gonna go to our developer
documentation and I'm gonna blow this up
as well and I go to my pipeline spec
right here we have a lot of different
ways that you can do that so you can
either initiate it in a cron job or you
can use git you can use some webhook
stuff as well but a lot of what people
do is so they they time it either via
cron to run like every second on
something or saw a repo and then as it
changes every time it changes it does it
or you could you work at the opposite
way to where your user requests you know
part of that JSON or whatever is telling
it to update a pike or PAC control repo
with that and then once pachyderm
recognizes that oh this data set or this
repo has had a new commit it kicks the
job off again right so yes any other
questions this guy up here in the front
I think is the second hand I saw if
you're in the back I'm sorry shout I
guess
hey so this may be my misunderstanding
of gdpr but I noticed when you were
going through the process flow of
removing a user's data in my head I was
curious if you were going to rebase or
delete the history of that and so to me
if you rebase you still have the users
data in that repo whereas if you destroy
the history then that could mess
recompete all the hashes and potentially
mess things up you actually thank you
you actually kind of caught me on that
so wasn't
anything past but yes he's absolutely
correct if legally in gdpr
when someone requests to be deleted as I
didn't bring that one up specifically
because someone else mentioned I just
got to change my slides would you be are
someone says I want to be deleted
that means everything about their data
has to be deleted there is no history of
this person they are then a ghost right
so in pachyderm we can remove that
person from that repo and they won't be
used to be trained in any future model
to delete that data they'd have to go to
the database of wherever that user lives
and then delete it and then if they you
know to really go through it you'd have
to go through specific figure out every
commit impacted room where that user was
used which isn't necessarily difficult
it would just be an extra step and then
kind of removing that from the commit
history and then it would like rebase
but what I'm trying what I was trying to
explain is like so if I wanted to if I
do PAC control delete file images master
dogs dogs or dogs I can delete that file
and if I do a PAC control this images
excuse me images master it's still there
what did I do
yep
there you go see look again you can't
type when someone's looking over your
shoulder I challenge everyone yeah there
we go thank you for catching that good
sir so you can see that file is gone but
realistically in the commit history and
all that other stuff that would be there
but you would just go through the
database of wherever this user
information lives delete it and then
even then you would could just kick off
your pipeline after removing that file
and the pipeline would rebuild and get
you know a future state to where or a
new model that's trained without that
user data however so I've had this
conversation with some of our
co-founders in depth and you know gdpr
is a good example and we are working
towards like an actual delete so when we
do a delete how do we go back and make
sure that all the hash trees and
everything or like that data isn't there
so that's something we're absolutely
working towards but like as a simpler
example you can remove files from
pipelines which you know is also part of
the GDP ah right you can't use that date
users data to train all mated systems so
hopefully that answers your question
but good catch good catch but alright is
there any other questions I hear Oh got
a question here I think again if you're
in the back you're just gonna have to
holler the lights are pretty bright yeah
there you go like the way it's like 2:00
in the morning or yeah so we can
leverage cron to do that so like say we
want this job to run nightly at 2:00 in
the morning you can just part of your
pipeline spec could be a cron job that
says you know go and fetch the latest
set of data and then it would kick off
the job and do it then and you can set
that cron job to be however often you
want and what's cool is because
pachyderm is everything is you know
again a docker image that's then
connected via a pipeline spec and then
obviously a repo of data that has all
this commit history you know piece again
piecing things together and then being
able to be very declarative on when
things run how things run what output
comes from what is kind of the whole
purpose of it right and then again of
course doing the scale so we and our
recent 1.8 announcement we'd like
increase it which was done let's see
what's today Sunday we did that Thursday
Friday we did like we upped our scale to
be at the petabyte level so you can
scale to like hundreds of you know
hundreds of millions of files that you
know the thousands of nodes in the
cluster and so like the biggest of
enterprises loads can happen in this
completely and pack it and be able to
orchestrate all that stuff being well
pachyderm is initiating it really it's
kubernetes that's kind of taking that
load and separating across the cluster
and you can leverage GPUs in there as
well so sorry I went a little bit past
your question but yes you can be very
declarative all the way down from when
your job runs to like what resources it
uses so hopefully that answers your
question ok are you compressing data at
all no ok so that's just massive amount
of raw data it's up to the user to
compress it yeah I think like it could
be part of your pipeline to compressed
data if you wanted it's all about you
again it's all about how you want to
declare things to be
if you have a step in your pipeline that
does compress data you could do that but
by default to my knowledge and I could
be wrong I'm on record here I think I've
the other recording button someone may
go oh no absolutely you can so you know
as far as I know where you don't
compress any data out out right like
it's not a default behavior but I'm sure
you know if that was part of your
pipeline you can do that any others and
try to keep an eye out in the back all
right well what I'll do is because
usually when I go to talks like these
you know people leave it at a demo but
they don't really give you a concept of
like where to go afterwards if you want
to play with it at home so really like I
said we're we're a bunch of open-source
nutcases at our company and so we pretty
much do everything on github and we have
a slack channel that's also available
open for users so you can join I'll just
pull up our website real quick not to
promote our product but really so that
you can just see if you want to get
involved ask questions without being you
know like super pressed for you know you
know everything we have a slack channel
we can join in you can ask any question
you want doesn't matter how simplistic
or difficult we all are very focused on
that our github is another great place
to go to find information see what we do
more discussion we are also starting to
with every release really starting to
put out more blogs about kind of giving
more insight into the backend of why we
change things the way that we did and
more in an engineering level so if you
want to see like how we change to go
from like the scale we were at
previously the scale we are now we have
a great blog post in there from one of
our the engineer who did all that who
explains like why we change and how we
changed things on an architectural level
I'm not that smart so I'm not even gonna
try to revert it because it'll sound all
kinds of broken coming out for me but
it's very cool post from him to take
time because we're just all about being
transparent and sharing information but
we have a lot of really good
documentation and examples to cover just
about a lot of so many different use
cases we go you know we can do database
stuff we can do genomics pipelines
Jupiter notebooks we have some like ml
stuff the one that you saw today that I
was doing is object detection so you can
follow this example out right
just lots of really good ways for you to
put your hands on on it and see how you
can take even you know any kind of data
that you have and then immediately
within just a few seconds it takes two
minutes to deploy pachyderm all of a
sudden your data just starts inheriting
this lineage this provenance that you
can use and gives your models a lot more
of a scientific approach which is
incredibly you know valuable and
multiple fronts and as far as I know I
think we're the only company that
provides this information or does that
data provenance at you know at this kind
of scale but yeah so check out our
github page jump on slack if you want to
ask questions and that's that's really
it unless you guys have any other
questions and I highly encourage in
there are no dumb questions except for
the ones that don't get asked oh there's
another one
yes have you seen I guess like so when
this pipeline is in production or used
on some tea with some team and they have
like tons of images right like tons of
data that when you try and pass it into
a different stage into prediction at
large batches like like is that already
just easily taken care of just you know
just like from like the just from the
pipeline itself or go ahead yeah so if
you're asking about yeah so you have
these so say you have these different
links I think you have like two
different David lakes is that you're
asking or you want to move data from one
side of the or I mean I guess it's just
like how well have you seen this perform
when you're when like your database or
like the data that's coming in is like
really large like off the scales really
huge yeah
so what's again this is pachyderm but
more so I think the beauty of kubernetes
like when we can take what we can do it
so I was really excited about this split
functionality we did with our 1/8 you
can take this really large data set and
I have a I have a blog out there but and
I can I mean I could show it to you
really quickly but what we can do is we
can take data in a single structured
file split it up into however many files
and we can specify how many file
we want to split it up into so by
default pachyderm will take a table of
rows and make each row its own
independent file and store the header
information with that file and so it'll
create you know X amount of files
however big your row is but you can also
tell pachyderm to say okay instead of an
individual file for each row I can say I
want every ten rows to be an individual
file in pachyderm so how that applies to
large data is if you whether it's
structured or unstructured or
what-have-you
it's all you know kind of object store
to begin with so it's how you know how
you move things from one object sort of
the others gonna really depend on speed
but as far as pachyderm ingesting large
amounts of data it's as simple as a put
command and it just kind of goes and
either breaks it out or does it but that
job that that independent thing is spun
up as a docker container to do all of
those things and then they get spun down
so it's it's really like kubernetes that
shines in that regard but yeah that
scale is there alright I think that's it
I'm seeing any hands all right going
once going twice I'm gonna be sticking
around to my flight doesn't leave until
later so if you guys have any questions
that you just want to be on the
spotlight for feel free but thank you
for your time and thank you for you know
everything
[Applause]